[MUSIC PLAYING]
DENNIS TROPER: My
name is Dennis Troper,
and I'm the product
director for Wear OS,
and I'm really, really
excited to be here today.
Let me start with a
little bit of history.
By the way, I need the clicker.
You know, when we first
started Wear OS four years ago,
we went out to see what people
were wearing, and what we found
was a tremendous amount
of diversity out there.
People really care
about what they wear.
It evokes their passion, their
style, and their personality.
The same goes with what
you wear on your wrist.
It's a really, really
personal choice.
And so from the start,
we made a decision
to bring lots of
choice and diversity
into the wearable space.
Today, we couldn't
be more pleased how
this strategy has played out.
We have over 50 watches
that are powered by Wear OS
today out in the market,
from top brands like Louis
Vuitton, Michael Kors,
Fossil, and many, many others.
Let me show you some of the
recent launches of watches
that we've introduced in the
market with our partners.
Back in the fall, for the
holiday season of 2017,
Misfit launched the
Misfit Vapor smartwatch.
The Misfit team did a
great job with this watch.
It has a very sleek
and stylish design.
It fits great on your wrist,
and it makes for a great fitness
watch.
Then this past
January, Kate Spade
launched the Kate Spade
New York smartwatch.
It's a beautiful watch,
and users are really
loving the Choose Your Look
app that matches your outfit
with your watch face.
And then this past March
at Baselworld, Hublot
introduced a limited edition
smartwatch called the Big Bang
Referee 2018.
This is a beautifully
crafted smartwatch.
It's body made out of
titanium and with a theme that
celebrates the most popular
sport in the world--
soccer.
I'm actually really
excited about this watch.
I'm a big soccer fan myself.
And get this--
referees are going
to be wearing the Big Bang
Referee at international
matches to help them connect
with the latest goal line
technology.
And that's really, really cool.
So we're really excited
about all these new watches
that are coming to market.
We've built a lot of
momentum with our partners.
To give you a sense
of that, in 2017,
we launched 26 new watches.
That's twice the
number of watches
that we launched
the previous year.
And an interesting stat-- we're
now seeing a lot of iOS users
in the Wear OS platform.
This past year, in 2017,
we grew 148% year over year
in iOS users.
And today, one out of
three new Wear OS users
activate their watches
with an iPhone.
And so this is why
last month we decided
to change our name from Android
Wear to Wear OS by Google.
We want a brand name that really
reflects the great diversity
of users that we
have in our platform,
as well as the wide
range of choices
of watches that are out there.
We're really happy
with this new name,
our partners are
really happy with it,
and our users are
loving it, as well.
So, you know, we've
learned a thing or two
over the last few years,
working in the wearable space,
and I want to share a key
insight with you guys.
It's a simple one and
perhaps an obvious one.
But the way people use watches
today is very, very different
from how they use phones.
They're very different in how
people interact with them,
how long they use it,
how often they use it,
and what they use it for.
With a phone, first of all, you
carry it with you all the time,
and you have two hands
to interact with it.
It has a large screen, and you
can spend a long time with it,
playing games, doing social
media, or responding to email.
With watches, it's a
very different story.
With watches, you carry it with
you on your wrist all day long,
but you use it
very sporadically.
And when you use it, it's
just for very short moments
to get some information,
and then the faster you
can be back doing
what you're doing
in the real world, the better.
So we've taken these
learnings to heart
in how we think of our
platform going forward,
and we are now focusing on
three very important areas
to improve the user experience.
Let me walk you through them.
First is connection at a glance,
second is health and fitness,
and thirdly is convenient help
from the Google Assistant.
Let's start with
connection at a glance.
In this day and age,
people are expected
to be connected all the time.
As I said before, we carry our
cell phones most of the day,
but there are some cases in
which pulling out your cell
phone is inconvenient,
or sometimes
we just don't have it with us.
For example, when you go out
on a run or on a bike ride,
or if you go to a fancy
dinner dressed in an outfit
with no pockets.
But in any of these
occasions, you still
want to be connected to the
people and the information
that you really care about.
You know, I myself am
the father of five kids,
and I also like mountain biking.
And I can tell you
from experience
having to put my cell
phone in my backpack
where I carry water is
just really inconvenient.
Watches-- smartwatches--
fill this gap really neatly.
They're very easy to access.
There's a lot of
computing power in here.
And this is one of
the key reasons why
users love wearing
Wear OS watches is
to help them have
the peace of mind
that they can be
free from their phone
but still be connected to
the information or the people
that they really care about.
And so this is an area that's
a really important, connection
at a glance, and we're
doubling down on it
to increase the user experience
and bring more to our users.
To give you just a
few examples of things
that we've introduced recently
in the areas of notifications
and complications, let me
show you real quick here.
Very recently, we introduced
adaptive text sizing,
which essentially
allows the glanceability
of the notifications to
be much, much better.
Because when you receive a
short text, the size of the text
gets bigger so it's
easier for you to read it.
We also introduced
recently darker backgrounds
and a new font type so we
can increase the readability
and fit more information
onto the screen at a glance.
We've also done things to
improve our complications.
Complications are
these bite-sized chunks
of information that sit
right on your watch face,
and they're very
handy little tools.
I myself, I use the
agenda complication a lot.
It really helps me many
times during the day
to tell me where I need to
go next for my meetings.
So we've done more,
because we think
this is an important area
for people to stay connected.
Very recently, we introduced
the notification preview
complication.
This is a very
handy complication
that brings the
top-ranked notification
right on your watch face.
Things like breaking
news, a chat message,
or your next appointment will
be right there on your watches
with this complication.
And we also introduced
another complication
that we called the recently
launched app complication.
This is one where
it's very handy when
you have types of information
that you like to access very
frequently during the day--
for example, the weather
or checking the scores
of a live game.
So this is just a few
examples of things
that we're doing to increase
the experience for connections
at a glance.
And as I said before, we're
doubling down in this area,
and you should expect a lot more
from us in the months to come.
Next is health.
You know, health
and fitness is one
of the most
important reasons why
people buy a smartwatch today.
People want to be healthy,
of course, and we at Wear OS
are very committed to helping
people lead healthier lives,
so we're doing more with it.
We're working tirelessly
to give users the ability
to track their health much
better than ever before,
and also to offer them a
more superior experience
to track their active fitness.
Let me show you just a
few examples of things
that we've done recently.
Very recently we launched a
feature called touch lock.
This is a great feature, for
example, if you go on a swim,
or you go out on a
run on a rainy day,
and you're tracking
your workout with Google
Fit or any other application
like MySwimPro, Strava,
or Runkeeper.
With touch lock
enabled, what happens
is that your screen
basically gets disabled,
your touchscreen gets
disabled, to avoid
any unintended behaviors
while your watch is
in constant contact with water.
To disable touch lock,
all you have to do
is click on the button, and
you're back into normal mode.
Next is music.
Music is a huge
deal for many people
when they're working out.
It helps them stay
motivated and energized.
And so we've made
accessing the music media
controls much, much
easier than ever
before from the Google
Fit workout screen.
All you have to do is
scroll down from that screen
and you get to the
media controls,
where you can choose
the next song that
will help power you through
the rest of your workout.
We're also doing a lot more
with the heart rate sensor.
We recently introduced
continuous heart rate
monitoring so you can check
your heart rate many times
during the day, and you can also
compute your resting heart rate
right from Google Fit.
So this is just a
few samples of things
that we're doing in
health and fitness.
As I said before, helping
people lead healthier lives
is core to our mission.
And we're working really hard
in many aspects of health
and fitness, and
we're going to be
bringing a lot of new
features in the coming months,
so stay tuned.
The last pillar that we're
focused on is the Assistant--
convenient help
from the Assistant.
You know, today, unlike
traditional watches that
are very good at giving you
the time, with smartwatches,
you expect to get the
best out of the time.
For example, in my case, I'm
very busy during the day.
I can quickly look
at my phone and be
able to check when the next
train leaves to San Francisco
so I can be home in time for
my daughter's soccer game.
We're working really
hard to improve
the experience for the Assistant
to optimize for the risk form
factor.
In a few short
minutes, I'm going
to invite Tom to come on stage.
He's going to tell us a lot
more about what we're working
on here with the Assistant.
So there you have it.
These are the three areas
that we're focused on
to improve the user experience--
connections at a glance, health
and fitness, and convenient
help from the Assistant.
But in order to do
this really well,
we require a very solid
and robust foundation.
Here, I'm talking about things
like power, connectivity,
performance, the companion apps
that go along with the device,
and so on.
Let me just highlight
three of them very quickly.
First, iOS-- as I
said before, we're
welcoming a lot
of new iOS users,
and we want those users
to have a great user
experience just like
anybody else that
is wearing a Wear OS watch.
Very recently, for example,
we introduced a brand new iOS
companion app that
brings Google Fit summary
stats right on the
app so you can see it
from the comfort of your iPhone.
This is just one
example of many things
that we're doing to
improve the iOS experience.
Next is power.
Power is really,
really important
when it comes to
smartwatches, and we're
working across the Wear
OS stack to optimize
battery consumption.
Right after Tom, we're going
to invite my colleague Rati.
She's going to tell us a
lot more about what we're
doing with Android
P and how this
has a positive impact in power.
And lastly, I'd
like to highlight
that we're bringing faster
and more frequent updates
to the platform.
That's really, really
important for our users
that they get continuous
improvements to the watch
constantly throughout the year.
With Wear 2.0, we made
changes to our architecture
so that pieces that
were considered
to be traditionally
part of the OS
are now updateable
platform components.
And as a result of that,
this past year, in 2017,
we were able to do 11
releases to the platform
and introduce 49 new
features and improvements.
This year, we're on track to
do the same or even higher.
We're introducing a lot of
features really, really fast,
and we're really
excited about that.
So as I said before,
the Google Assistant
is one of the key pillars
that we're working on,
really, really important for us.
And I'm going to
invite Tom on stage
to tell us a lot more about it.
TOM RUDICK: Thank you.
Thanks, Dennis.
Hi, I'm Tom, and I work on
the Assistant for Wear OS.
We want the Assistant to follow
you across all of your devices.
And when you interact
with the Assistant,
it should adapt to the
device that you're using.
And for Wear, we want to provide
an awesome Assistant experience
right on your wrist.
With our last update
this week, we've
completely redesigned our UI and
have three major improvements
that I'd like to
talk to you about.
First, we have an always
present microphone,
which automatically reopens
to continue the conversation
with the Assistant hands-free.
Second, support
for text-to-speech.
If you have a paired Bluetooth
headset or a wearable device
that has a speaker, when
you talk to the Assistant,
it now can speak
right back to you.
And lastly, my favorite,
support for suggestion chips.
Suggestion chips
allow you to breeze
right through a conversation
just by tapping.
But the biggest new
addition for Wear
is support for
Actions on Google.
Actions on Google allow anyone
to write a great wearable
experience without
having to write
a single line of Android code.
Even better, most existing
actions already work on Wear OS
today without any changes.
So let's take a look
at how this works.
You may have already
used Dialogflow to build
actions for the Assistant.
It's a platform
provided by Google
that helps to turn natural
language into a format
that you can just go and
build cool stuff with.
And starting this
week, you can also
use Dialogflow to create
actions for Wear OS.
Best of all, we've already
done all the hard work
of building out
response templates that
are appropriate for
wearable devices,
so you don't even have
to think about it.
If you haven't used Dialogflow
yet, it's super easy.
Just yesterday, I was
creating my own action.
I only had to define
this action once,
and it will work across
all supported devices.
Here's what it looks
like on mobile.
This might look pretty familiar.
There's an action
icon at the top,
a tapable list of the Google
I/O sessions I plan to go to,
and a suggestion
chip at the bottom.
And this is how
it looks on Wear.
All the same components
exist, but now they're
tailored for a smaller,
wearable form factor.
I didn't have to do anything
special for this to happen,
it just works.
And now, even if you're
going a little bit deeper,
and you're using the Actions SDK
or a webhook for fulfillment,
we still have you covered.
In this case, I'm
adding a new card
to the conversation that has
a little more information
about this session.
And this is how the card will
render on both phone and Wear.
It automatically resizes
and looks great, regardless
of which device is being used.
So over the past few months,
we've been building and testing
a lot of actions, and we've
come up with some best practices
to help your actions look
really great on Wear.
Let's start with an example.
OK Google, ask Bay Trains when
is the next BART from Fremont
to Hayward.
There's supposed to
be an animation here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- There will be a
BART from Fremont
to Hayward leaving
today at 11:21 AM.
[END PLAYBACK]
TOM RUDICK: Cool.
So as Dennis
mentioned earlier, we
want users to have glanceable
simple interactions.
We want users to get
tasks done quickly.
We want to allow
users to complete
a task with a single phrase.
In the previous example, I was
able to get the information
that I asked for by
speaking a single phrase.
Imagine if I had to specify all
the information separately--
the train that I
wanted, the station,
the direction of travel.
That would take
way too long, and I
would be far more likely
to just pull out my phone.
Keep your dialogues short,
concise, and task-oriented.
Now, there are
cases where having
a back and forth
dialogue is important
and maybe even required,
and that is fully
supported on Wear today.
However, try not to make it
part of your core user journey.
As you may have just heard, Wear
now supports vocal responses,
and they don't have to be
the same as the visual.
In the previous example,
both the visual response
and the vocal response tell
me when the next train leaves.
That's what I asked for.
But the visual response
goes a step further
and shows a more detailed
list of departures.
That information would probably
be a little bit too dense
to read aloud vocally, but
visually, it works really well.
Independently, both the
vocal and visual response
makes sense.
But together, they really
complement each other
and make an awesome experience.
Keep in mind that not all
devices support vocal feedback,
so you can use
surface capabilities
to really tailor your
experience to the device that's
being used.
So vocal responses are cool,
but my favorite new feature
is suggestion chips.
So I have to admit
I'm a little nervous.
Last few times I came
to Mountain View,
it rained, and I forgot my
umbrella, got soaking wet.
I know it looks like a
nice day out there today,
but let's ask the Assistant
to see how things look.
OK Google, do I need
an umbrella today?
Cool, not expected to rain.
This weekend I was planning
on going for a hike,
and I can use suggestion
chips to get that information
quickly--
the weather for this weekend.
I can just drag up on the bottom
drawer where the microphone is
located, which will
reveal suggestion chips,
and I can tap on weather
this weekend to quickly get
the forecast for the weekend.
The weather looks great.
I should bring my sunscreen.
I love suggestion chips.
Not only are they a great
way for guiding users through
a conversation, they also
allow users to discover what
your agent can and cannot do.
Provide example chips whenever
possible to guide users
through a conversation.
When thinking about how to build
your action, be user-centric.
Someone might be
using your action
in a lot of different ways.
They might be on the go,
their hands might be full,
and vocal responses might
be more appropriate.
Or they could be
somewhere noisy,
and suggestion chips are
the easiest way for them
to tap through an interaction.
Design with all these
use cases in mind.
We've had a lot of fun building
support for Actions on Google,
and you can get started
building your own agents today.
I'm so excited to see what
you're going to build.
And if you need
some inspiration,
we have a lot of great
partner demos in our sandbox,
and you can come by
after the session
to say hi and check them out.
And if you're interested
in building actions,
I definitely
recommend to check out
the "Design Actions for
the Google Assistant"
session, which starts right
after this one on stage 2.
But don't go just yet, because
up next is Rati to tell you
about our platform updates.
RATI AGRAWAL: Thanks, Tom.
Hi.
I'm Rati.
I'm a technical program
manager working on Wear OS.
Tom just showed you how to build
really cool Assistant actions
on Google for Wear users.
Now let's move on to the
platform updates that we have.
With the new Wear OS
release, we are introducing
platform features
that will help you
to offer delightfully stable and
battery-efficient experiences
throughout your apps, and help
you build really cool watch
faces with just a
few lines of code.
To begin, I'd like to
talk about an Android P
feature that is going to
impact you as a developer.
Android P is adding restrictions
on accessing methods and fields
unsupported by the SDK to
improve app compatibility
and to prevent
apps from breaking.
Wear OS is adopting
these restrictions
with the goal of
making app behavior
deterministic and stable.
This is very similar to what
the developers on my team
face just before
a product launch.
The deadlines and
restrictions can
make people a little
unhappy as they're
dashing to meet the deadlines.
But come launch date,
the team is really happy
when they're able to launch
a stable and reliable product
that meets our users' needs.
So check out the app
compatibility link
g.co/dev/appcompat to understand
what these changes mean
for your apps.
Moving on to battery--
battery is precious on mobile,
and even more so on Wear.
Last year at I/O, we highlighted
that most watches have
just 1/10 the battery
capacity of a phone,
and we shared some
best practices
on improving battery life.
We also indicated that we
would be looking for ways
to be more aggressive than the
phone in addressing battery
usage.
This year, we are moving
beyond the mobile platform
and introducing features to
reduce background activity,
aggressively turn off radios
when the user takes off
the watch, and enhance
battery saver mode.
Let me walk you
through some of them.
Here's a snapshot of
the app Standby feature
that was introduced
in yesterday's talk,
"What's New in Android P."
On Wear OS, we're experimenting
with a more aggressive platform
change.
Apps that are not
active will not
be able to create
jobs or alarms when
they are not on the charger.
Now, even when they are
in the active bucket,
they can only start
jobs or alarms
if they are in the foreground.
What do you mean by foreground?
Well, an active app running in
the foreground is an example,
a watch face currently
active on your dial,
complications on your
currently active watch face,
and in very rare
circumstances-- say,
if you're a health
monitoring app--
a foreground service
running on the watch.
All of these can
create jobs and alarms.
If you are a Wear app
developer, be sure to experiment
with these changes in
the developer preview
and provide us with feedback.
Another platform feature that is
being revamped in the upcoming
release is battery saver mode.
We are enhancing this mode to
go beyond the phone platform
to aggressively squeeze
that last ounce of battery
and prevent the watch from
turning off on users' wrists
during the day.
In this enhanced version
of battery saver mode,
we would be turning
off all radios,
touch, and tilt
detection, and would
be defaulting to a
battery-optimized watch face.
Users can short press to
read the time and long press
to resume full operation.
This could be
particularly helpful
if your watch is
running low on battery,
but you want to quickly
be able to turn it back
on to, say, make a payment or
to check an important message.
Continuing with our efforts
on improving battery life,
last month we moved to using a
dark theme for our system apps,
as Dennis mentioned earlier.
Now, this theming
has the dual benefit
of improving glanceability and
accessibility while reducing
power consumption.
In P, we're bringing these
changes to the platform
and updating the default system
UI to use the dark theme.
So try these changes out on your
app using the current developer
preview.
I'd like to leave you with some
best practices for watch face
design.
As you know, watch faces
are the most active apps
and frequently are doing
too much too often.
As developers, you
have the ability
to influence how long
users get experience
and enjoy your watch
faces using simple coding
techniques to save battery.
Let me share a few best
practices with you.
Display, CPU, and
network are the most
battery-intensive
components of the system.
Be mindful of the
frequency at which you
are reading, processing,
or displaying information
on a watch face.
For example, if you're
reading a sensor
and doing calculations
every minute,
or sending an RPC to the
companion every minute,
this can significantly
impact the battery life.
And once you have the new data
from the sensor or the network,
you would also have to wake
up the system to process it.
Processor wakeups are more
expensive for battery life
than the power consumed
by individual sensors
like the accelerometer.
So batch you sensor
requests and network calls.
Batching can go a long way
in conserving battery life.
Finally, moving on to
some developer tools.
Last year, Android,
and as a result,
Wear OS, officially
starting supporting Kotlin.
Now, you can already
take advantage
of a lot of language features,
like compile time null
checks and Lambda support.
But to get the
best out of Kotlin,
we need to go beyond what the
language offers by default.
On Wear, we are experimenting
with creating a Domain-Specific
Language, or DSL,
for watch faces
so you can get rid of a lot
of the boiler plate code.
The initial results
are quite exciting.
We reduced the watch face
creation code of 600-plus lines
to just under 15 lines of code.
And here's a snippet of
what the DSL looks like.
This simplified interface allows
you to focus on the design
and customize your watch faces
using just a couple of lines
of code, while incorporating
best practices to boost
the performance and battery
life of your designs.
We're very excited
about the opportunities
that Kotlin provides
and are just
beginning to scratch the surface
on simplifying development
on Wear OS.
We look forward to
your feedback while we
work towards adding this
to our official SDK.
Check out the code labs at I/O
and visit the Wear OS sandbox
to share your
feedback and ideas.
To summarize, use officially
supported methods and APIs
instead of private APIs
to improve compatibility
and stability of your apps.
Design your apps and watch
faces to be battery-efficient.
Remember, batching
is your friend.
Download the P developer
preview and check out
how your apps are impacted by
the battery-saving features
that we are introducing.
And finally, give Kotlin DSL
a spin using the code lab,
and let us know what you think.
With that, let me hand it
back to Dennis for closing.
DENNIS TROPER: Thank you, Rati.
All right, to recap,
we're working really hard
to improve the Wear OS
experience in three key areas--
connections at a glance, health
and fitness, and a Google
Assistant experience that
is optimized for the wrist.
We're also improving
the platform
with new battery-saving features
and new tools for developers.
And also, you can expect a
lot more and frequent updates
from us during the year.
Today's session is just
the beginning for us
here at I/O. At 2:30 PM,
we have office hours where
you can meet with our
engineers and our developer
relations folks.
Come on by if you
have any questions.
They'll be really happy
to receive you and talk
to you about anything that
you like to talk about
in regards to Wear OS.
And at 11:30 AM tomorrow, we
have an app review session
where you can bring your
Wear app, your complications,
or watch faces to get
feedback from our engineers.
And we also have a sandbox.
Here's a map of where it is.
Please come visit us.
Tom, Rati, and I will be there
right after this session,
as well as many of our
colleagues at Wear OS.
We also have some cool
demos there to show you
and a full lineup of some of
the most recent Wear OS watches.
That's all.
Thank you very much for
coming, and have a great I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]